(cello music)
- No.
- It's gotta be true.
We don't have slavery now
at the very, very least.
- I feel like probably about the same.
- Fuck, do we have slavery still?
(cello music)
- I know that this is gonna
disappoint me (laughs).
(cello music)
- [Voiceover] I would have
problems with somebody
who embraced all the doctrines
associated with Islam.
- Islamaphobia started
during the terrorist attacks I think.
- That has to be now, right?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Individual Moslems
may show splendid qualities
but the influence of the
religion paralyzes the social
development of those who follow it.
- Now.
- I'll still say now for this one.
- This sounds like it comes
from the mouth of someone
who's just sheer ignorant now.
I am not, nor have been,
in favor of bringing about
in anyway the social
and political equality
of the white and black races.
- Is it then?
- Then, right?
- Oh, wow, that's interesting.
It's kinda weird to hear this
and hear where it's coming from.
- [Voiceover] I mean you
got the first mainstream
African-American who is
articulate and bright and clean
and a nice looking guy.
I mean that's a storybook man.
- Now.
- Then?
- Joe.
- Wow.
Biden.
- [Voiceover] Every immigrant
who comes here should be
required within five
years to learn English
or leave the country.
- Definitely now.
- I definitely think that's now.
- Definitely sounds like
something people would say now.
- [Voiceover] They're
sending people that have
lot's of problems, and they're
bringing those problems
with us.
They're bringing drugs.
They're bringing crime.
They're rapists.
And some I assume are good people.
- Is it right now?
- This is Donald Trump, right?
This was really hard.
- I felt like all of these
quotes could've been said now.
- I feel like that girl
from Mean Girls all the time
where I just wish everyone
could be happy and get along.
- History repeats itself,
and this kind of just shows that.
(cello music)